foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsey show where America hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life and your money so it's a free call
anywhere in the country at triple eight
eight two five five two two five talking
about your life your job your career
your money your relationships anything
and everything we are here for you and I
am at Ramsay personality Rachel Cruz
hosting today with best-selling author
and Ramsay personality Christina Ellis
yay I'm so excited to be with you I
don't know we've done a full show we
haven't it's our first two days in a
while since Christy has left Christy
Wright who we miss so deeply but uh so
it's fun to have have another lady next
to me so have the girl Vibes I love it
yeah and and obviously we bring kind of
a unique take because of that so if you
are a mom out there with questions about
kids or jobs or Child Care anything
around balancing life and kids Christine
and I are in the thick of it yeah our
three little ones seven and under and
you have two I have two one and four
years old one in four years old years
old we're in the thing we're barely
surviving here let's just say that if we
make it through three hours like with
with trains of thought you should just
be proud of America let's be honest
that's a lot it's a lot but again we're
taking your calls at Triple Eight two
five five two two five okay we're gonna
start out with Daniel in Miami hey
Daniel welcome to the show
hi how's it going ladies doing great how
can we help
so I had a question I'm 22 years old
um looking to go into a graduate program
in the next year to two years and I have
a pretty good credit score right now and
since I would have to take significant
student loans out for the programs I'm
thinking of
um would it be wise to go ahead and pay
off all my credit cards and lose my
credit score knowing that I'm going to
have to apply for student alone soon
well Daniel I'll be honest with you you
called the Ramsey Show so we're not
going to be the ones to advise the
latter part of your question of taking
out a lot of loans for grad school and
actually Christina talks so much about
scholarships grants and going to school
debt free so I'll let her jump in here
in just a second
um so yeah to answer your question yes
if you pay off all of your debt uh and
you don't have any debt it takes about
anywhere from nine to 18 months for your
credit score it's going to keep going
down down down down until it hits
undetermined because the way your credit
score is mathematically calculated is
all around debt and if you don't have
debt they can't calculate a score so uh
our yeah the way our stance my stance is
that the indication that you are winning
with money is not an indication of the
credit score and how high it is and what
you do with it it's it's a
non-negotiable for me just to not even
think about it and worry about it
because being out of debt is the first
priority so Christina jump in here and
talk to Daniel because grad school it's
a real thing because if you have a want
or even college degree right undergrad
even
um a lot of people listening it's a it's
a dream of theirs or for their kids and
they feel like the only way they can do
this is through student loans yeah we
hear so many stories where people are
coming in with student loans and grad
school is largely responsible for the
massive debt so it is really important
to kind of talk through especially with
grad school because I feel like it's
such a vulnerable space for people to go
into debt Daniel what are you thinking
about doing in grad school
um so it would either be medical school
or pharmacy school okay and what's your
undergrad degree in
uh it's in biology okay well we talked
to a lot of people I feel like medical
school is kind of the like hard question
we get a lot of times where people it's
a little bit harder to pay for med
school debt free but we do have a lot of
people who come through here who do it
you just have to be really strategic so
I would encourage you to kind of like
slow down a little bit and really think
through and do the research on what are
your options out there we often talk
about the MD PhD program which is a
great option for going debt free it's
pretty competitive which is often kind
of the flip side of that but there's
also other options you could potentially
you know go into the military and go
that route I know that's a big decision
you could go to a cheaper School you
could slow the pace down a little bit
and pay as you go which I know is
challenging but I would encourage you to
kind of explore other options I can kind
of hear in your voice that the
assumption is that you have to go into
debt and that's kind of been your
journey so far but just even today if
you can take a pause and think through
what would it look like for me to go
debt free and see if you can shift your
mind to even consider the possibility of
everything you do moving forward when it
comes to college is going to be done
without debt
and what's amazing with that Christina
is and again it's a total mindset shift
right because like you said it is a
people just kind of yield into higher
education with loans like like that's
that that's the pathway you go and
there's no other options and so
um when you just have this absolute in
your mind that we're absolutely not
going into debt for this that's not an
option so now what do I do what are my
other options right because people whack
you in the corner and say well I either
have to take out loans or I can't go I'm
like no there's options b c d e over
here if you look but you but people
don't take the time and the energy to
look at all those other options because
it is easy yeah to sign a student loan
to put your name you know put a
signature down and worry about that
later when you feel like oh we're gonna
be making good money and it's all
justified in your head well and
especially with med school I feel like
that's kind of the spot that gets really
overwhelming because you see all these
doctors with huge student loan debts and
that's the thing is we interviewed
somebody in our documentary borrowed
future where they had a million dollars
in student loan debt so it's like yes
they got a med degree yes you know I'm
sure they're happy to be a doctor
ultimately but they're literally crying
in the documentary because they have
crippling amounts of debt so
med school it's great right but if it's
going to equal an extremely stressful
long-term outcome I mean even pumping
the brakes on that and kind of going is
is med school right for me if it's going
to cost a lot of debt you know maybe I
could be a nurse practitioner maybe
there's another option in a medical
sphere that I want to do debt-free yes
and just to even just harp on that too
Christina because I'm like
you know when you don't have debt and
you're debt free or you choose to live a
life without debt there are St there are
so many options out there to look at and
when you think about debt it's like this
is my one way it's a one-way tunnel and
the outcome is usually what we end up
seeing on this show often is not good
like that one-way tunnel usually ends up
being a lot of stress Dr John delone
even talks about like your body that
book your body keeps the score the
amount of stress that you Harbor and
like the amount of anxiety and Consumer
Debt has that the the graph has been
consistent year after year after year
which is fascinating but what it does to
your to your relationships your minds
um just the ability to to have something
clear because you don't owe anyone
anything if that makes sense so right so
options give you power they give you
power either options of choosing not to
take on student loans and look at other
options and then again when you don't
have debt you have the freedom to make
to make decisions you're not stuck in a
job you hate to pay bills you know
you're not you're not stuck in this life
it really is this level of Freedom we're
like I can have creativity and think
through what do I want to do because I
can because I don't owe anyone anything
absolutely yeah that's such a good
feeling and I think that there's also
this myth around higher education that
like I'm gonna get this great income so
no matter how much debt I have to take
out it's going to all pay off and I'm
going to have this great job and this
great paying degree I mean I even heard
that whenever I was visiting Schools
they're like you know this is how much
it's going to cost but don't worry don't
worry like you're going to have a great
job afterwards and you're gonna be able
to pay for it it's no big deal and so
that's not true like we've seen people
with great jobs with student loans that
are still struggling and feel like
they're suffocating so that's right just
kind of separating that out and being
like even though you may get a great
salary debt can still be very stressful
and suffocating very much so very much
so I'm Rachel Cruz Christina Ellis
hosting today with me at Triple Eight
two five five two two five give us a
call we'll answer your questions this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Ramsey personality Rachel Cruz hosting
today with Ramsey personality and
best-selling author Christina Ellis and
we are taking your calls
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five and we're answering anything
and everything so whether it's your
career your money your relationships
your life give us a call and yeah we'll
chat about it have a conversation
hopefully help guide you uh with any
question that you have in your life so
again give us a call Triple eight eight
two five five two two five and we have a
a full Lobby today Christina out out of
the glass right there a bunch of people
came in uh and your husband yeah okay
biggest fan love it so fun but just a
reminder that you can visit us here
right outside of Nashville in Franklin
Tennessee at Ramsey headquarters and you
can get cookies you can get coffee
cappuccinos lotsies americanos they have
all the fancy stuff Christina they do uh
and I just found out like two weeks ago
you get a free coffee mug I just found
that out too yeah so make sure you get
your free coffee mug everyone out there
in the lobby uh so that's a fun gift so
yeah be sure to come and visit us live
and then of course the debt free stage
is here where we get to take calls live
all the time of families and people that
pay off all of their debts all right up
next let's go to John Carlo in San Juan
Puerto Rico hi Giancarlo welcome to the
show
Hi how are you ladies doing we're doing
great how are you doing in Puerto Rico
we don't have many international calls
so I appreciate that
yeah you're welcome you're welcome so
I'm calling because I have a potential
job opportunity coming up towards the
end of the year
um over in the states and then like my
current situation is I have around 2014
in debt but the huge majority of that is
on the car 18 000 of those is in the car
um and I'm currently working on getting
current in all of my bills which I
should be done with
um within the next month now my question
is
um during the month of November and
December should I
save up and plan just in case this move
does happen and then if it falls through
I just dumped that into maybe step
number two or should I continue with the
baby Stitch and only start saving up if
the opportunity comes up so if the
opportunity comes up would you be moving
in January
I'll be moving somewhere around that
time fitness around the time it should
be around six weeks yeah okay so it'll
be a pretty quick turnaround
um for you do you have any other money
saved besides baby step one
no I do not okay
no that's great
um I mean honestly John Carter and we we
tell people to pause baby step two for
with very you know very small
circumstances in a sense like they're
like not a lot of times do we say
deposit so uh big life change though is
always a little bit of an asterisk so
you know if you're expecting a baby for
anyone listening we always say during
pregnancy to pause baby step two pile up
some money make sure everything's good
um even if you have to replace a car
because maybe you sold your car and
you're having to get a new one to get
through the debt snowball quickly we say
you can pause for a short period of time
to save up to move on to that and then
another one in this category Giancarlo
as I would say if you have a big
transition like a move coming and you
know it's there and you don't have the
the funds to be able to do that properly
but you know like you said that it's
that there's a good chance it's going to
happen
um I would be okay with you pausing baby
step two four for 60 days and see what
happens in January and just like you
said uh you're still gazelle intense
right you're still sacrificing you're
putting money aside but you're putting
cash aside so if that move happens you
can do that debt free and and move but
if it doesn't then just like you said
throw it at maybe step two and uh which
will be a great motivator still so not
losing the motivation of it but where
the funds are specifically going uh I'm
okay if you pause that for 60 days and
wait to see if this moved because I want
you to have some cash on hand if that's
the case yeah that's great it's always
good to have that extra cushion when
you're making that big change I am kind
of curious too where are you guys at in
the negotiation process have you all
talked about the possibility of
relocation expenses because with such a
big move there's a chance the company
could offer some help in that transition
yeah so
um they did say that there was um some
relocation help but I do not know of the
details but the main reason why we
didn't go through that at the moment was
because
um of what I got told you I'm currently
trying to catch up on current and I was
explaining my situation so what they
said is hey
um like they're pretty much going to
give me these couple of months to see
and then they're going to touch base
with me in December to see how I'm doing
um and see if I get all of that sorted
out because by the time that I have this
call I needed to catch up in a round
um 1.5 k
um in bill so by the time that they call
I should be already caught up in uh
comfortable
yeah and and that's great because that's
what we encourage you to do even before
you start paying extra in your debt is
you want to get current on all of your
bills so that's going to be number one
regardless of move or not right that
you're going to be catching up and be
caught up on all your bills uh and then
beyond that is saving that money so what
what kind of job are you looking at
so I'm looking at a sales job
um yeah I'm looking at a sales job the
main reason why I'm thinking of a career
change is because I've been working on
the server and you know for me it's been
going great for the past two to three
years my average income has been
anywhere between three to four K and as
a 25 year old in Puerto Rico where the
minimum wage is 850 an hour it's great
but yeah there's also the position the
potential chance to
um around that same time me and my
girlfriend might get engaged we're about
to start going for pre-medical
counseling and if that's the case you
know I'm thinking of I want to start
switching to something that could be a
career you know thinking of growth for
my family specifically
that's amazing well congratulations
that's very exciting you have a lot of a
lot of things in Flight it sounds like
Giancarlo yeah
that's great well awesome thanks for
thanks for giving us a call but that's
um yeah that's exactly what I would do
make sure you're caught up and obviously
I think the company wants to make sure
that you're in a stable place
financially especially if you're gonna
be in sales and very high commission
they probably want to make sure you
you're okay and you're not going to be
drowning uh in in payments uh and bills
it's awesome that you're doing all this
too before you get married like the fact
that you're taking the time now getting
caught up wanting to pay off your debt
wanting to figure out this career stuff
that's just going to build such a
foundation for your marriage so good job
on you know really digging into this and
getting intentional right now yeah
absolutely thanks for the call all right
up next we have Dave in Cleveland hey
Dave welcome to the show
thank you for taking my call I
appreciate it absolutely how can we help
uh just have a question about a way that
I should proceed with a um an investment
that I have in terms of the house I have
a house in um another state I'm
currently living in Cleveland you have a
mortgage on this property it's about 345
um K right now and the other house is um
it's going to be paid off in about five
years we ended up renting that out we
moved just about two years ago
so obviously it has appreciated in value
um significantly oh about 65 left on it
and I'm guessing it's probably ballpark
maybe you work about 400 right now
um and my question is with how the stock
market has declined so significantly I
kind of expect that over the next couple
of years to recoup and would like to
consider selling the other house and
putting the money into some mutual funds
that may increase more than the rental
that I could get out of the house
yeah
um I I would agree with that assessment
um I love real estate I come from a
family that loves real estate so I'm not
against rental properties uh the only
thing I don't care about this situation
is that you're a long distance landlord
is that correct
uh yes I have someone essentially
managing poverty yes so just owning
property owning a second property with a
second mortgage is kind of we don't care
for that and being out of states or far
away a long distance situation it just
makes things more complicated when you
can't have your own eyes on the property
so yes Dave if I were you regardless of
the stock market or not I would still
advise you to sell the rental I mean
it's done great in equity if you get 400
I mean that's that's incredible but what
I honestly would do next is I would take
some of it I would invest some of it you
know 15 uh and then I would throw the
rest at your house do you have any other
Consumer Debt
I do not have any other debts in the uh
than the two mortgages right now that's
perfect well and another another reason
I was sort of thinking about selling it
was I'd saved quite a bit of money I do
believe in taxes because I've lived in
it recently enough to have to pay the
capital of the game so i that's correct
yep that's awesome well yeah I would
sell it and I would throw I would throw
some into the market 15 and then the
rest have to write your mortgage and go
ahead and pay off your primary mortgage
this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more verse
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
so in the news you mostly are hearing
about the market the stock market and
just the ups and the Downs Downs towns
that we've experienced with that and
what you're not hearing as much about is
the real estate market you know six
months even a year ago people thought
it's going to be the biggest bubble and
it's going to crash and as we all are
experiencing it is not going to crash as
a reminder this is not 2008 we are in a
completely different type of economy at
that point at this point when it comes
to real estate there are still more
houses out there or not as many houses
half as many homes out there than there
are buyers still right now in Fall of
2022 and prices you know everything is
softened for sure it's a slower rate we
have all felt that but the truth is you
know when you're ready to buy a house
it's when you're ready not when the
market says you are ready and so you can
still win in the Rose say market today
so if you're looking to buy a home or
sell a home it is still a great chance
to get in the market and one thing that
you want to make sure that you do is
that you win when it comes to your real
estate agent you want someone with
experience someone knows what they're
doing and so here at Ramsey we have
actually vetted all like a lot of the
local agents in your area to find the
ones that are top-notch and that we
recommend here at Ramsey Solutions so if
you want to connect with a Ramsay
trusted agent for free go to
ramseysolutions.com agent and check out
our endorsed local providers program
again that's ramseysolutions.com
agents it really does make such a big
difference to have a great agent we
actually sold our house in May with a
Ramsey ELP and they got the highest
price per square footage and our whole
area wow I was I was very excited about
it well and I feel like two people
people appreciate really really good
agents these days I think because it is
such a a you know competitive market
where it was easy to kind of slip into
the hole well I'll just use my
grandmother's friends granddaughters
cousins dog walker and they're a real
estate agent and so I hear they're great
and we're going to use them right like
people fell into that so often but this
is your largest
your most people's largest financial
purchase that they make in a lifetime it
is a big deal when you enter into buying
a house or selling a house so having
someone that knows what they're doing is
so so important it's a game changer for
sure all right I'm Rachel Cruz with
Christina Ellis hosting the Ramsey Show
today so give us a call at triple eight
eight two five five two two five we are
taking your calls on life and money up
next we have Tom in Columbus Ohio hey
Tom welcome to the show
thanks Rachel Christina how are you
we're doing well thanks for calling how
can we help
super I am um getting a little bit ahead
of myself because I'm not quite through
with the debt snowball yet but I'm just
a couple months away finally so I see
the light at you oh congratulations
thank you and in that I'm so excited to
use my money for something other than
paying off yeah so I'm mapping out you
know the emergency fund the investing
and all that kind of thing that's where
my question comes from okay it's very
exciting so when I get to that point I'm
hoping to be there after the first of
the year do I start investing at the
same time as well as cleaning for like
529s for the children and things like
that yeah it's a great question so we
actually want you to have a fully funded
emergency fund first so how quickly do
you think you'll get three to six months
of expenses saved
no Dad I'm hoping within three months
okay yeah absolutely so um so once
that's completed then I would recommend
taking 15 of your income and setting up
a plan to invest in retirement and so
you can you know if you have a 401k at
your work or 403 b a Roth IRA and just
hitting that 15 of your take-home pay uh
with that and then the next step would
be yes looking at kids colleges so how
old are your kids
8 10 12. awesome
yes so that that would be sitting down
and starting to plan for for college
yeah and I love that you're already
feeling so much drive around that I feel
like that is kind of like seeing that
light at the end of the tunnel is just
so exciting and I know I kind of heard
like a sigh when we talked about the
emergency fund but you're almost through
that that is just awesome and as
somebody too who focuses on the college
space I would encourage you to obviously
do 529 start saving money for college
but also start having the conversations
with them about what finances will look
like with college talk to them about
money help them have good money habits
and get them prepared to win
scholarships because I mean that's one
of the biggest keys to success a lot of
people wait to the last minute to talk
to their kids about money and then they
have no concept about what that's going
to look like for college and that's how
we ended up in a student loan crisis but
if you start prepping them early they're
probably going to build a resume that's
a lot more likely to stand out for
scholarships so just having those
conversations in multiple directions
could be really helpful Chinese
Financial Peace junior is on its way so
that's exciting
a little more detail
um with that question about the 529s if
you could please do I do three separate
or do I do one and change the
beneficiary no I would do three separate
yeah I would put one
um have have each child have their own
um I was actually Winston I a few years
ago when we were sitting down with our
um with our smart Master Pro actually
our investor
um our investing professional that we
sit with uh once a year we were talking
about kids college and Tom yeah I mean I
I kind of threw that out there I was
like gosh because what if one doesn't go
to college right like all these
questions come up and is it smarter to
have it in one and they and they were
still recommending no have it in each
because it's in each of their names and
if something happens
um you know that they still have their
own account there for them that they can
take and then you can even pass down
generationally which they can do for
their own kids yeah and that's the good
news is it's like if you if you save a
little bit more for your 12 year old and
your 12 year old ends up getting
scholarships and doesn't need as much
you can pass that on to your 10 year old
and same with a 10 year old to the
eight-year-old so definitely and then
beyond that right yeah isn't there yes
even multiple and if you want to go back
to school you can even use it for your
own education like it can be shared
within the family yes which is awesome
but yeah thanks thanks for the call Tom
all right next up we have Michael in
Durham North Carolina hey Michael
welcome to the show
hey thank you for taking my call
absolutely how can we help
all right so um I'm 20 years old I am
working full-time I moved out of my
parents house and I'm kind of thinking
about going back to college I tried
going to college right out of high
school and didn't really work out for me
I just kind of spoofed off the classes
and wasn't paying attention and um I'm
kind of considering going back for
software engineering and I'm just not
sure if if that's a good idea or not so
I'm working full-time
um with as a fiber engineer with at T
over here and RTP I'm making about four
grand of after taxes every month and
there is room for growth here
um but most of my co-workers and uh the
people who have more experience they all
have college degrees and they are
offering a reimbursement program for me
to go back to school how amazing and I'm
just not sure if I can juggle working
full time and going back to college
so I was just wondering what the old
Insight was on that now if you go back
to college are you strictly considering
a four-year degree or are you open to
maybe some sort of I would I would I
would go to a community college here
um which would keep the cost down and
um probably just start doing part-time
classes see how that goes and then maybe
ramp up the classes a little bit more if
I can handle that and if I'm comfortable
with it so that's kind of what I was
thinking about doing but I wanted to run
it by you tell me a little bit more
about your like motivation for going
back obviously there's the income Factor
but you talked about how you went to
college before and kind of you know
didn't didn't continue on with it are
you feeling pretty excited about going
back right now yeah I I am
um I have two older siblings who both
went to school for I.T and
um they're probably doing great they did
well that's what I was gonna say yeah
and oh no I was going to just say I bet
they're doing well
yeah they are and they really enjoy it
and I feel like
I I just I've always enjoyed um working
with computers and I really just want to
get back into school but I don't want to
give up my job at the same time or maybe
not give 100 to both of those things
because
I need my job to you know pay for my
rent and my bills I have a thousand
dollars saved up and I'm working on my
emergency fund awesome awesome Michael
well that that's incredible so yeah if I
were you I think definitely taking some
classes yeah I mean it's paid for yes
online and at night take your time
you're 20 years old even if it takes you
an extra year to do it in three years
you could have a degree be making a
great income because that is a great
field of study to go into and if you
want to check out Ken Coleman's get
clear assessments if you hold on the
line Austin will pick up and give you an
access code to that because that could
also help you kind of guide you even
more specifically on what you want to do
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting today with Christina
Ellis and taking your calls so up next
we have Heather in Denver hey Heather
welcome to the show
hi ladies thanks for taking my call
absolutely so my question is
um so I'm currently on a 30-year fixed
rate mortgage at a rate of 2.625
um after getting connected with Dave
we're trying to pay that off early and
our goal is to put an extra 12 000
towards that mortgage
um a year we were talking to a financial
advisor who brought up putting that
extra 12 12 000 into a brokerage account
with the goal of paying the mortgage off
in 15 instead of 30 and then the
interest that's earning money on the
brokerage account for interest for 15
years and then whenever we have the rest
of our mortgage we're at that 15-year
period then pull out the remaining
balance of our mortgage to pay it off at
that point
um he said because with the interest
with our mortgage interest rate being so
low and the interest rates we get on a
brokerage account that he think we'd
actually end up making out better and
still being able to pay the mortgage off
early I was wondering what your guys's
thoughts were on that yeah so
financial advisors they love math
besides you just threw all those numbers
at me uh yeah and that and and I would
say mathematically Heather
I get it right like I mean we're not
we're not dumb we see the math and we're
like okay yeah I understand that but
what is not factored into all of this is
risk that when you have a house payment
there is still there's a level of debt
that you carry that still has it debt is
risk and so that is still there and on
top of that uh you never can factor in
the fact of what happens to your mental
emotional relational space in your head
when you don't owe anyone anything and
so there's this game that can be played
mathematically so whether it's what he's
saying and it's like Well yeah if you
just put in this brokerage account you
know mathematically it makes more sense
because you could pay it off in 15
instead of 30. uh some people say well
just invest the you know invest that
instead of paying off the house because
you can make more in the market that you
know there's all these ways around it
but honestly Heather after doing this
stuff at Ramsey solutions that we've
been talking about for for 30 plus years
we still recommend just paying it off
early throwing throwing money at the
principal extra every month like you
were saying uh and and watching that go
down because there's a part of the math
too or I'm sorry part of a part of this
equation that is so much of your
behavior and the motivation of seeing it
we just uh did some pictures and signed
books in the in the lobby and we had a
wonderful couple show us their picture
of their house with a bunch of balloons
and they're having they're coloring it
in on all the extra payments that
they're making and to pay it off and
there's like this motivation when you
start to watch that go down that again
math doesn't play into that equation but
there is something about that human
Spirit element that is so so real
Heather
um so that's where I would disagree with
your financial advisor and I would just
start paying down that principle yeah it
may not be as exciting to to throw the
money in a brokerage account while
paying off your mortgage and actually
seeing that progress is Awesome with the
brokerage account you it's easy to have
those best laid plans and say yeah we're
going to pay it off early through this
really creative strategy or the song old
strategy that mathematically makes sense
but then the opportunity to go on a trip
comes up or you know some other
Temptation maybe you see a little bit
more expensive of a car and there's just
other temptations that can easily kind
of cut into that motivation
um to really knock down the house versus
actually seeing the mortgage payment go
away which is pretty awesome have you
guys done the math Heather to figure out
okay how much how quickly do we think we
can pay this off
um Matt well it depends on how much
money my kids continue to cost me mostly
over the years we feel bad that's true
more and more at it and so I'm hoping
for you know closer the 10 years but
currently with no math changing I think
15 was realistic okay
yeah and what what's fascinating Heather
do you have any other Consumer Debt or
anything any other payments uh no we've
we've never carried debt okay that's an
awesome mortgage amazing amazing so yeah
that's people that are doing the Ramsay
plan
um where you're investing 15 of your
income into retirement kids college and
paying off the house early on average
we're seeing people pay off their homes
in seven to eight years and that's on
average we see it lower we see it higher
sometimes so
um that's also part of this factor that
yeah math on paper is showing you uh one
number but I'm curious once you guys get
going and you know and as life
progresses you know you you could get a
raise bonuses like other stuffs can
start happening in your life where you
can have more money to throw at the
mortgage and actually accelerate you uh
and just your motivation so yeah and it
sounds like you guys are really good at
money like I feel like you're the type
of people that with a plan and with a
very clear goal and Target like you all
are going to tackle this pretty quickly
and probably be on the the quicker end
of that seven day years
yeah we stick to our plans and we are
both very cautious with our money
um but we also don't understand the
financial world yeah for sure for sure
well uh I would recommend to Heather to
check out our smartvester Pros if you go
to ramseysolutions.com and sit down with
one of those financial advisors because
they're gonna they teach what we teach
here and that's how to get out of debt
as quickly as possible and to be able to
invest well uh so they're gonna be able
to look at your entire Financial picture
even your retirement and everything
because yeah that's our goal for you is
is to get that baby step seven where you
have no debt no payments and you can
live like no one else and give like no
one else as well so uh it sounds great
Heather you you guys like you said
Christina motivated you're you're smart
and I feel like you guys can pay this
off really early much faster than 15
years yeah and I appreciate your honesty
of saying you know hey we don't know a
lot about money we don't know about
finances and it can be so tempting when
somebody throws out that math to say hey
if you do this like you can earn this
and it's going to be exciting because
then you can do this and you can throw
it can kind of feel overwhelming and
with our principles they're really
simple and they're not very like they're
not very like complicated we're just
basic Common Sense math but it works
over 30 years we've seen so many people
on that stage doing debt-free screens
that just went through the steps they
followed a plan it wasn't the sexiest
flashiest newest hottest like modern
plan but it's gotten Grandma's way of
doing finances and it works we see it
all the time so it's exciting seeing
people you know the beginning phases of
this plan the people out in the lobby
with the home chart who are filling out
those bubbles and just watching that
progress absolutely and there's a
there's a true you know you said yeah
Grandma's always been handling money and
God's ways of handling money when you
look at at even scripture which is how
we we filter our lives through when
scripture says that the borrower is
slave to the lender
there is a real true sense of that that
when you have payments dead of any kind
the mortgage is the one type of debt we
don't yell at you for and we even say
you don't have to be gazelle intense
with the mortgage we had a call
yesterday and the guy's like I want to
pay off our house but my wife says she
needs a new car because she can't go in
reverse we're like oh my gosh get her a
car like there's a time and a place
right to be that intense uh when you're
paying off your Consumer Debt so again
the mortgage is the one that we will not
you know yell at you for but we do want
you out of it as soon as possible
because if a pandemic happens if you
lose a job like anything and everything
when you don't have that liability when
you don't have debt in your life again
we said it earlier but it's true you
just have options and there's this peace
of mind to be like what do I want to do
with this money it is all mine and that
that mindset I think emotionally
spiritually mentally is what does not
factor into formulas yes that people so
easily can go into when it comes to
money because it's easy just to do the
math but that's a small part of it right
right the behavior changes why is so
huge the freedom the feeling the the
people who come across that stage you
have no mortgage the the lightness they
walk with is just amazing and it's so
inspiring and it's like you can't just
have that with numbers and and some of
this advice that keeps you in debt
longer I mean like the 30-year mortgage
at 2.65 that feels tempting a financial
advisor might be like hey stay there but
like being out of debt in seven to eight
years that's amazing versus staying
there for 30. yes that's right that's
right so we we talk about all these
subjects uh here on the Ramsey show but
we also are traveling doing Live Events
this fall and this coming spring which
we are so excited about so how we cover
relationships career money anything and
everything here on the Ramsey show we
also cover those subjects on the road at
the Smart conference so here in a couple
of weeks we have our biggest event it'll
be close to 6 000 people in Dallas Texas
uh so it'll be all the Ramsey
personalities Dave Ramsey Dr John
baloney Ken Coleman Christina Ellis here
to my right George Campbell and myself
Rachel Cruz so make sure to get your
passes at ramseysolutions.com events to
get your tickets uh it is October 22nd
in Dallas so make sure to see us there
and thank you to everyone in the booth
and thank you America for listening
we'll be back
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsey show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting for
the PODS of moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsey show where America hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life and your money I am at Ramsey a
personality Rachel Cruz co-hosting the
show today with Ramsey personality and
best selling officer Christina Ellis and
so we are taking your calls at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and we're talking about yeah your your
relationships your life your money and
Christine and I are here I have three
little ones at home she has two so we
talked about taking calls from you
parents out there if you have child care
questions or concerns when it comes to
money and the budgets we can talk all
through that that balance of being a mom
and working what does that look like in
seasons of Life anything and everything
related to the little the little
children yes especially for those of you
who are in the thick of it like us yes
just talking about child care and
babysitters and and just all of it on
the break just for our own personal life
so we'd love to talk about it with you
here on air kids getting their tonsils
out the whole thing we're experiencing
it all here in our houses
so yeah give us a call Triple eight
eight two five five two two five all
right starting us off this hour we have
Mike in Las Vegas hey Mike welcome to
the show
hey guys happy Wednesday happy Wednesday
to you as well Mike thanks for calling
appreciate enough thank you guys for
taking my call so
um yeah long time listener uh pleasure
to be here and uh basically without
getting too Lost In The Weeds my
question is I'm
um on the verge of receiving a um
inheritance that I was listed as a
beneficiary for
um which will come out to about 40 40K
40 000 in total
um I was a bit of a financial right a
couple years ago that I worked myself
out of
um and so I currently I guess the Crux
of the question is how to best like
allocate that money
um currently working full-time
um I have about ten thousand dollars
left in student loans I've brought it
down from about 50k to 10 000.
um I have about eight thousand dollars
left on a car payment or a car loan uh
no credit card debt I rent so there's no
mortgage
um and I am currently in in school
working towards a master's degree in
computer science and that's going to be
about another eight grand left that I
have to pay for the entirety of this
first year into you know year two and so
those are kind of some of the bigger
ticket items I'm looking at and just
wanted to see what your thoughts were on
how to best kind of attack these
different remaining debts um and you
know other kind of things and where to
kind of allocate those funds yeah that's
great well my great job working your way
from fifty thousand dollars
of student loans down to 10 well done
thanks yeah that's amazing
um and what a gift uh when it comes to
this inheritance was it someone that you
were were close to that passed recently
when I was younger yeah um much closer
to was my my aunt um and she passed
earlier in this in the year uh and so I
you know along with other family members
was listed as a beneficiary and so it
was just um you know one of the things
I've never really been through that
process before and so I'm trying to just
understand okay you know where can I use
this you know wisely and so far as like
you know the allocation is concerned
yeah well I'm so sorry for um for her
passing and your loss
um but what a what a what a beautiful
um Legacy though that she left and that
you're able to to use this money uh not
just to go and Yacht around the
Mediterranean and spend it all but to
really use it to to benefit your life
and to get you in a better situation
financially so I think it's a it's a
great question and I Ai and I always
appreciate that well because we talk
about Legacy here so often when you can
use it for something so great for you
and even your your future family
um I think it's just a beautiful picture
so I'm thankful you called yeah and
because of the work you've already done
and paying off those other student loans
it's you're really going to be able to
knock out potentially all your debt with
this which would be even more beneficial
with the Legacy it's like you'll have
something really beautiful and concrete
to cross the finish line with this
inheritance absolutely that's right yeah
and that that's one of the bigger things
is really kind of knocking that gut out
which I could I could do currently just
with my like salary I could I'm working
towards that
um but you know with the
um one of the kind of questions I had
and I know I've heard Dave talk about
this on on the show but
um the big kind of X Factor is helping
you guys could touch on and I know what
he said which is whether this remaining
ten thousand dollars which I qualify for
um you know that student loan
forgiveness thing that may or may not
come through yeah you know ever bet on
that but that does come through do I you
know how how do how do I factor that in
yeah totally well so if I woke up in
your shoes tomorrow Mike and I had this
forty thousand dollars I would go ahead
and pay off the 10K student loan pay off
the car take eight grand from that and
keep it for the rest of your masters
that you said you need and that leaves
you fourteen thousand dollars left and
that's a great depending on your
expenses you know emergency funds uh so
you could be well on your way just the
baby steps four five and six
um you know well beyond that which is
amazing with this with this money so
with the student loan forgiveness I
wouldn't wait on it if it does actually
go through which is a big question if it
will obviously uh if it does though they
will refund you uh the money if you want
that so if you pay it off now you can
still apply for a refund uh and still
and still get that so if that's
something you wanted to do you could
still get that money if you decide to go
that route
yeah that kind of gives you the best of
both worlds you can kind of get that
yeah wiped out straight away and then
also get it back if that ends up being a
thing and I mean we should find out
pretty soon they've said literally at
the beginning of October the application
should be out so we're all kind of
waiting on pins and noodles in this
space kind of going okay is this gonna
happen when's it gonna happen how's it
going to look so I mean potentially in
the next month we should have some
pretty concrete info so maybe like if
you want to wait a month
um I mean that wouldn't be the worst
thing just to see if this actually goes
through but also just paying it off now
and getting that refund could give you
that peace of mind and you could be yeah
into the next step because there's
something to Mike I mean and people got
mad at me when I said this on the show a
few weeks ago but it's just the truth
for me I'm like there's something
proactive that you've already been doing
Mike like you've already paid off fifty
thousand dollars like there's something
proactive about life and when people
really win they have this mindset that
they don't wait on someone else to take
care of them they just do it like they
just do it and you're handed forty
thousand dollars a beautiful gift
so I'm like do something proactive with
it and so for me I'm like man that same
motivation
um and that same you know proactiveness
that got you here my kid still Propel
you forward and again if it all goes
through and in six months you apply for
the refund you get the 10K back or
whatever it is then good for you that's
awesome then you can apply that to to
investing or or maybe a down payment on
a mortgage uh but I would just hate to
keep waiting and waiting and waiting and
being in that mindset and it's almost
that more passive approach than
proactive approach so I think that um
yeah I would use this and go right down
that list of car student loan 8K set
aside for grad school and then you still
got 14 left to to use as an emergency
fund so I think that you're in a CR
incredible position to do some
incredible moves right now financially
yeah that's awesome so great thanks Mike
for calling this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer
so head on over to netsuite.com Ramsey
to get a product tour today that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show we are
taking your calls at AAA
825-5225 up next we have Molly in Boise
Idaho hey Molly welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for having me
absolutely how can we help
um so we are California transplants for
one of those oh yes we know you Molly we
know you all too well that's great
that's great yeah so we're building a
house here in Idaho we
signed our contract about a year ago we
got locked into our interest rate at
3.875 when it goes from construction to
mortgage
however our lock is going to expire one
month before the house is done oh no
like pain and we're now being quoted a
rate at 7.5 percent of course
which is again more pain for sure it
definitely knocks out that 25 household
income level
for our mortgage
um so we've been like looking into other
options
um this option makes me cringe a bit
being a Ramsey girl but um we were
suggested to look into a five-year
interest-only arm just to see what
happens within the next few years and
decide if interest rates go down then
refi to a traditional mortgage or sell
the house then
yeah how much was how much do you guys
bring home a month
um roughly 10 000. okay and what what is
your mortgage payment currently on the
construction loan
with a three points apparently we're
just
uh it would have been 2 900 a month so
it would have yes and then what will it
be now
about 43. oh
yeah
and
um more bonus we are expecting our first
baby in three weeks so a wonderful
pregnancy brain on top of it oh well
congratulations
thank you uh what do you and your
husband do for a living
um I work for a company that sells Micro
shares and race horses okay it's very
exciting
um and my husband works um in fly
fishing okay that's awesome
um because I'm just trying to see it all
of this movement of the 10 Grands
uh a month that you guys bring home if
there's going to be any
um like if you see any upwardness in
that dollar amount when it comes to your
careers and seeing okay here in the next
like maybe two three years do you see a
significant change in that income at all
um there's potential for it
um the company that I work for purchased
my old company so I got
quite a good stock option in that
um
so there's money there and then there's
also I have upward Mobility that I can
move and make more money
um
but I don't see it being
so significant so that yeah
I know I know
have you had conversations with the or I
guess what have your conversations with
the builder looked like just in terms of
timeline and kind of what their
reasoning is for the the timeline being
a bit longer what's kind of their
feedback on all this
covid
and sum it all up all their excuses are
Supply chains covid it slowed us down
they were supposed to have it done in
six months it's now going to be done in
over a year or so it's just like do you
in one of those things whenever you have
you talked to them about this this
timeline and when when it expires
um about like if if there's any chance
they could get it done a month earlier
what's kind of their thoughts on that is
it just like a hard no
it's a hard no unfortunately like we to
get it to where it is where it's only a
month longer was them moving it up as
much as they possibly could I'm also
wondering like is there any chance that
they could like offer an incentive
because obviously they don't want to
lose you at this point like you're
already under contract for this house
they want to sell this house you know
other people are feeling the pain of
interest rates changing is there any
sort of incentive of like buying down
the rate or something they could offer
you to kind of help this out like if
they could buy it down from 7.5 to 5
um is that a possibility that you've
explored at this point
I have not explored it I'll definitely
ask them about it I have a feeling it's
not going to fly
um the way that their contractor is
written is very much covering their butt
no matter what happens
so but unfortunately like their station
they're not going to be covered if you
if they lose you as a buyer like that's
going to be you know a loss for them as
well so I just wonder from a negotiation
perspective
um if you can kind of just sit down with
them you know it's going to be a little
bit nerve-wracking because you're
emotionally invested I can hear it in
your voice it's scary to think about
losing your house but
um I don't know whether you know it's
better for you to have a conversation or
your husband but go in with a little bit
of hard ball of like hey these delays we
are not responsible for these delays
like we could potentially end up losing
this house and have to walk away that'll
be a loss for both of us so what can we
do now what can you offer us how can you
help us make this situation work out
mm-hmm I like that a lot
yeah I'm sorry you're in the situation
though that's hard especially with a
baby coming being moms that last month
is so vulnerable and you just want to
nest and be comfortable so I'm just
yeah my heart goes out to you
I mean one one very positive thing is we
are
we have an insane amount of equity in
this house like since we've been
building it to now like
um just to give you some numbers we're
in for 6.75 and a house down the street
that's 600 square feet less than ours
two bedrooms less just sold for 1.1 oh
wow
we are looking really good in that area
yeah well I was going to say if you did
have to turn around and sell it uh that
was my question so you're gonna get I
mean you're gonna
almost doubled but it's just amazing uh
and I know you probably don't want to go
through the whole process of uh building
again or something but that does give
you the options to actually let this
home or your future home be a blessing
because yeah Molly I just I I don't want
to get I don't want you to get an arm uh
for more the adjustable rate mortgage
it's just that is a gamble I would not
recommend that and then yeah and I don't
get it yeah and then you moving in with
a new baby you guys making 10 Grands and
almost half of it going right back out
into this mortgage payment this house
what was supposed to be a a blessing and
a wonderful thing and a gift and an
exciting dream is gonna end up being a
nightmare and it's going to be stressful
you're going to be frustrated that you
don't have more margin in your budget to
do stuff I mean it's it's gonna it's
gonna pull so much where you don't have
the margin that you could if the numbers
look different and so at that point you
know there's or a house is not worth it
like it you know what I mean like that
specific house in a scenario like that
um so yeah I'm trying to think of other
options for you whether it's what
Christina said or and someone probably
that feels like a high interest rate too
I mean I know I know rates are going up
but even if it was closer to that five I
don't know if you can go shop that or
look at different options when it comes
to that
um I mean I would do as much research
turn over as many rocks as possible
before you make that decision but if it
gets down to it and that this is still
the final situation uh then like you
said the Silver Lining is you're gonna
have some incredible Equity
um to be able to go and do something
else are you guys currently renting or
do you do you own the home that you're
in right now
we are renting a one-bedroom Airbnb okay
very cozy here with the baby that's so
sweet thank you dogs that's great
um so yeah I I would probably which is a
heartbreak but but look to see you know
what else is on the market and what else
you guys could do
um are you do you guys have any other
Consumer Debt
no we are baby steps three four five
awesome awesome I mean four five six
four five six yeah no you're great yeah
that's awesome well and with that option
of having that amazing Equity if the
option ends up being that it's going to
be best to sell the home and you've kind
of worked yourself through the emotions
of this may be a thing we may have to
end up getting the home then selling it
and taking out this Equity I think that
could give you even more confidence in
the negotiations like if you do go to
the Builder and you're like hey this is
where we're at like if you end up
knowing you're going to keep the house
in salad anyways like just giving you a
little bit more confidence in that
negotiation of saying like hey what can
we work out and even potentially
shopping different lenders talking to
different lenders you locked in with
these people a while back but maybe
there's someone else who can offer a
different rate maybe your lender can
offer us yeah that's what I was thinking
Molly I would go talk I would go talk
and get get three different options on
the table just to give you peace of mind
that you're making the right decision
when it's a one-track thing and this is
my only options all we have that never
gives you options and I just love
options so go search that out before
anything but I'm sorry Molly but
congratulations of the new baby oh it's
gonna be wonderful newborn phase is hard
but it's great but it's great so thanks
for calling
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com Ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
foreign
[Music]
well we know a lot of you are planning
on moving it soon and I've got great
news so our new studio sponsor PODS
moving and storage wants to help one of
you move for free that's right so just
to get a quote at pods so get a quote at
pods.com Ramsay between October 3rd and
October 14th to enter to win and it's
really just that simple and one of you
listening right now will get a free move
or a free storage rental that's up to a
5 000 value so look pods just makes
moving easier it has flexibility that
you need the control you want and the
customer service that you deserve if
you're looking for a company that will
help you move on your terms pods is the
only Ramsay trusted moving provider out
there so go to pods.com Ramsay and enter
to win a free moving or Storage Rental
today that's pods.com Ramsay
so Christina as uh we are two moms with
little ones my oldest is in second grade
so she's in full-time school public
school and it just it's so great it
feels great it feels great you're like
wow that's so nice our second we'll go
to kindergarten next year and then
Charles he has two more years so then so
I feel like we're kind of seeing the
light at the end of the tunnel of just
kids being in full-time school yeah five
days a week which is great uh but we've
been in that season for seven years now
of me working kind of on and off
depending on the the season
um and and how much travel I have and
you being a working mom now you know
when you have little ones at home there
has to be someone there if you don't
have a spouse that is staying home and
so for a lot of dual income families
which is a majority of Americans a lot
of Americans are a dual income family
you're having to look at options for
child care and it is so expensive we
feel the pain of looking at the budget
knowing what it costs and it's a real
factor and already people the margins
are so slim in life you know because of
inflation and everything we're dealing
with in the economy but also just the
reality of the stats that we know of the
personal finance state of a lot of
people in this country of just living
paycheck to paycheck with Consumer Debt
with wages not going as high as they
were expecting I mean like you know you
you bundle it all together and it can
feel very stressful and you you've
pulled some stats Christina from this
week of some of a survey a study that
came out from care.com yeah there's the
2022 cost of care survey it reveals that
the cost of child care is higher for
families in 2022 51 of parents say they
spend more than 20 percent of their
household income on child care and 72
percent of parents report spending 10
percent or more and they also say that
the quality of child care continues to
be tough for parents to find in fact 43
percent of parents say it's harder to
find Child Care over the past year since
the pandemic and parents continue to
struggle to pay for child care 59 are
more concerned about child care costs
now than a year prior which is driving
significant changes such as taking a
second job reducing hours at work
changing jobs and leaving the workforce
entirely so it's such an important thing
to talk about because I think a lot of
people feel like they're struggling in
this alone they feel kind of overwhelmed
and just kind of trying to trudge
through it but I mean obviously we want
to give hope and encouragement we've
been there I I mean for our family
personally I have a one and
four-year-old we've tried so many
different forms of child care from
Parents Day Out programs to full-time
child care to having a nanny it's like
it's a lot to kind of process and I
think it's so important to just bring
these conversations to life because in
my field I've been talking about college
for years and paying for college and I
see so many families stressing out about
paying for college and
it's crazy to see the studies the
average cost of child care per year for
preschool is similar to the cost of
in-state tuition at a public university
yeah which is wild what's the average
public university right now tuition just
under ten thousand just under 10 000 a
year and that's what we're seeing with
child care happening which is yeah so if
you're feeling that pull that's a real
pull like if you're feeling that stress
and that anxiety that that is a real
thing to talk about and discuss and to
be super strategic and intentional with
that's right and just like anything else
in the budget uh looking to see okay
what uh what are the where are the ways
that we can cut if we can what are the
different options out there that we may
have to plug into different than we had
to three four years ago you know because
life has changed and depending on your
job your financial situation you know
this may be an area in your budget where
you say okay what if we look at some
different options that actually may be
able to save us what we're paying now
which possibly could help so there's a
lot of different options out there yeah
for families yeah there's a lot of
different options I was telling Rachel
on the break that even as an
entrepreneur for so many years before I
came to Ramsey my husband and I tried
some non-traditional options for example
I would wake up for a season at 4am and
work till nine and that you know until
my son woke up and then my husband got
off at three and he would take him and
then I'd go back to work and I know it
wasn't ideal but it saved us a lot of
money and it allowed us to have a lot of
time with our son which was great in
what we wanted in that season of life
and then we've tried full-time Care at
other times so it's it is definitely
situation dependent and I think it's
good to kind of explore different
options some people have family nearby
some people have you know friends that
maybe do a nanny share there's just so
many different options versus
immediately signing up for that
expensive daycare that's like around the
block from you for sure for sure yeah
the nanny share thing is huge I know a
few friends that do this and it is
helpful if you're able to split because
you're able to go a third right of the
cost of what you would normally pay if
you can get two other families with you
if it is something like that and
sometimes it's more convenient like for
yes for some people you know they're
looking at a 15 20 minute commute to put
their kid in a certain program versus a
nanny share might be with your neighbors
where all you have to do is like walk
across the street to take your child to
share the nanny with you know your
neighbors across the street yeah and
then there gets to be a point too
Christina we talk to women on the show
too that after paying for child care or
even the commute from where they're
working if they're working outside the
home to somewhere else to this this that
they just say gosh it just it's easier
for me just to go part-time and that I
work two days a week and take that cut
because of what we're saving in child
care and in Computing gas all of it so
it's just it is so dependent per family
situations and everything but um but it
is it's a huge part of people's budget
and are part of our both of our budgets
that we see when it comes to being a mom
and working and so
um yeah it can be stressful yeah and
then also it's just important for people
to explore different options that can
like help with those costs some
employers now are offering benefits for
child care and so that could be a good
conversation if you're looking into a
new job if you have a job and your
benefits are pretty generous you know
see if that's available and if it's not
are they willing to negotiate that into
your package because I mean every little
bit helps if you can get an extra five
to ten thousand dollars a year to help
with that then that's amazing and also
talk to your HR department some
employers offer dependent care accounts
which then you can pay for your daycare
and pre-tax dollars which is obviously
going to be a great savings so just
being really intentional to see what
options are out there you know what
could possibly you know what am I not
thinking about are there any options
outside of the box that could really
make our lives easier and help our
budgets yeah for sure and just to
remember too that you know everything is
a season everything is a season and that
you know these costs aren't unless you
move to like private school and you're
gonna be paying for education at that
point or something kids are expensive
but if you if you're looking at it or at
least I am I'm like okay you know in my
head the amount of years that they're
that they're home and the days I'm
working when I need help versus when
they're going to be full time in school
right like that that's a season so it's
not going to be that forever expense
That Daycare uh even though that expense
can move too if you pay for a private
school elementary school or something
um but uh and also again I've had
friends that they're like yeah the
pulling back thing is is a real thing
just to say you know maybe it's Child
Care expense and other things uh where
they say okay for a season for this two
years I'm gonna do this a little
differently just to kind of ease the
burden of that of that bill that and
financially we're going to cut the
budget or people that say hey we're
going all in and our and we're just
going to have a tighter budget uh during
the season of having to put our kids in
child care knowing that that's going to
relieve you know have a little bit of
relief here in the next few years yeah I
mean for this season I have a full-time
stay-at-home dad husband which is the
right season for us right now and like
I've said we've been through it feels
like all the different options at this
point and for this season that's what's
right for us that's right and yeah we're
owning it yeah and I think too you know
the the key word here is options it's
options don't just feel like you're
stuck in one thing explore ask people
look at different you know
availabilities whether it's a nanny
share or even a different daycare
anything to kind of give margin to the
budget if it's needed uh there are
options out there but it can be tough
for sure this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting it this hour with
Ramsey personality and best selling
author Christina Ellis and we are taking
your calls at triple eight eight two
five five two two five all right up next
we have it James in San Francisco hey
James welcome to the show
hey thanks for taking my call how you
guys doing absolutely we're doing well
thanks for calling how can we help
um so my question in a nutshell is
whether or not I should take out a loan
for a family medical emergency that has
just come up
um so I have I have um I've saved up an
emergency fund I don't have any debt
um and I'm just working on saving up for
a house right now
um there's about 50 000 with all of that
and the medical emergency that came up
essentially my fiance is from another
country and she'll be here in a few
months her mother was just diagnosed
with cancer and
um
so in the medical system there is is not
very good the the government medical
system
um her grandmother had passed away from
uh having cancer and being on that
system and it could take like months for
treatment to come through and
so they've been trying to look for
options financing options loans and
things like that and I essentially have
just enough with all of that my
emergency funds and what I've saved so
far for a house to pay for the treatment
and Transplant that's needed
um what kind of cancer is it
um liver cancer not really sure what the
exact type is okay where is she from you
said just from a different country
yeah South America okay
and is your fiance here in the states or
is she living abroad as well
is she living abroad as well she'll be
here in a few months we just got
approved for a Visa a few weeks ago
okay what country specifically just
curious
um
Columbia
what is their what is their Public
Health Care system like
um so it's it's like uh I think it's
like a free healthcare type of thing I
think the citizens get just like very
basic health care
um
and essentially what it is I know what
her grandmother what her grandmother had
experiences they'll pay for the
treatments up to a certain expense
um and then once that once they pay for
once they run out of money for that they
basically tell you you can only have
treatment like every four months or
something like that have they started
into treatments right now have they
started into that period of provided
Health Care
well they haven't done that provided
Health Care they've they've basically
what most people do there is they go to
private clinics or private hospitals
because
those are
um more equivalent to like the treatment
you get here it's just very very
expensive and they've gone through one
they've started the chemotherapy process
but only one of them and I'm not sure if
they're going to continue it unless we
can pay like an initial like twenty
thousand dollars
when are y'all you said your fiance when
are y'all planning to get married
um early next year as soon as she gets
here basically you have like 90 days to
to do it how long have you guys been
together
a year and a half okay
I'm sorry y'all are going through that
that's hard when you're planning a
wedding you're trying to move with your
fiance over here that's just a very
heavy burden to try to process through
especially with you not being there
that's a lot to kind of work through
expenses when she comes like you know
moving and getting a furniture and
getting married and all that stuff yeah
I'm trying to save up for that for sure
um so James when you have
um ask the questions about costs and
everything when it comes to healthcare
done there what answers are you getting
is she looking to do a more private
Clinic type of
um you know health care or is she going
to be staying in the public when you say
I have fifty thousand dollars saved and
this can
help put her through treatment is that
have you have you run the math and you
have all the facts and you know what the
bills are going to be everything like
you're you're pretty certain on that
yeah pretty certain on it it's it's 20
it's 20 it's 25
000 first uh and then another basically
the 50 000 will pay for the treatment
and Transplant and then there's another
thirty thousand dollar cost after that I
guess that pays for the whole thing but
it sounds like that extra cost is just
once they get that 50 they kind of will
take care of everything and then there's
I'm assuming that extra is just paying
um
paying the rest of it sort of as like a
loan
um but yeah they're looking at Private
health care because it sounds like if um
to go through the the system it
it might not turn out well seeing as
what happened to her grandmother sure
sure
um well the only thing the only like
question mark I have mine is I just
don't know what Healthcare looks like in
Colombia right like if this was in
America we could talk about insurance we
could talk about company like we could
have more of a directed path so I don't
I don't have a lot of knowledge when it
comes to the healthcare system in
Colombia and so it would just be me
taking your word that this amount is
gonna be fine and that there's another
thirty thousand dollars but they're
going to waive that just like you said
like at all I I don't understand it all
um and so I mean what I would say to you
James is like this is your money
um I want to say you're not obligated
right to do anything right um like if
this was your your wife who I know she's
about to be uh your your child like you
when it comes to those kinds of
relationships like you would go above
and beyond right and for some people you
know their their parents extended family
you know whatever it may be when it
comes to medical expenses and if you
have the means to be able to help in I
just don't want to put you in your
situation in unsteady with an unsteady
Foundation
um so I'm thankful that you don't have
debts you you feel like you have margin
of your budget because you've been able
to save up this emergency fund and this
is for your house so if you made this
move
um and helped her with this and and
really gifted her that fifty thousand
dollars I think that that's extremely
extremely generous uh and kind if that's
if that's the decision you chose but
um but also you want to be able to to to
know okay for my fiance and I who's
gonna be my household you know what are
we going to have to do what moves um are
going to be on pause for us uh a lot of
things that you guys want to go forward
will have to go on pause so I want you
to map that out as well it's not saying
that's a reason not to do it
um well and I think like while this this
is a more emotional conversation there's
a lot more at stake to some to many
extents it's still kind of a similar
conversation that we have when an
Engaged couple like has somebody who
wants to pay off their fiance's debt
like until y'all are married there's
still a chance that this could not work
out and like if this relationship for
some reason I obviously hope it works
out but if it doesn't work out you know
you you potentially have really impacted
your own personal finances yeah for the
long term I think I feel a little bit
better if it was your wife that was down
there or you know soon to be wife and
you know getting married in a month and
this is a conversation where you know
you're gonna for sure be a unit in the
near future I think it'd be a little bit
of a different conversation but there
still is that risk of time and she's not
here she doesn't have her paperwork done
yet she's not living here in the states
yet so it's just a lot could happen
between now and then and that's such a
big amount of money that you've worked
really hard to save up that could yeah
potentially be gone yeah there there's
some there's some caution there James I
mean honestly and if there's any way and
again I don't know how far
um
how how in Decline she is health-wise
but I think that there's a safeguarding
for you that if you guys were married
like Christina saying so I don't know if
there's a way to to wait on some of this
or maybe you give a small portion for
now and then wait till you guys are
married and and then you're able
together as a couple to to send more
yeah or even start in the Public Health
Care system use up those benefits you
said that you know there's a certain
extent to which is provided and then
they make you pay maybe do those for the
time being until you all are married and
she's here and things are a little bit
more stable that's right so yeah it's
just it's just being really wise about
it James and again it's not us being
unkind or not generous I just have those
are some of the red flags that we have
um just you know where you are
relationally with her making sure that
you know you guys are married because
once you are you know then there is a
little bit of that different
conversation because you've
have a vow with another person that
you're going to do life together and if
that is like okay we're gonna do this
for for your mother-in-law again very
generous and very kind if that's what
you all decide and making sure there's
no weird red flags with the health care
System there that the my he's actually
going to her treatment I mean all of
that right there's so many of those
questions
um but again if this all works out and
you're able to help I think it's a very
generous thing and money is a tool
that's what we use money in our lives to
help enhance our lives and to give to
others and so if this is the route you
guys choose it's very very generous
Christina great hour thanks to everyone
in the booth thank you America this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsesolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the Pods at Moving and Storage
Studios it's the Ramsay show where
America hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money I am
Ramsay personality Rachel Cruz
co-hosting this hour with Ramsey
personality and best-selling author
Christina Ellis we are taking your calls
at AAA
825-5225 anywhere in the country it's a
free call so we are talking career
relationships money anything and
everything so give us a call this hour
starting us off is Jerry in Ashland
Kentucky hey Jerry welcome to the show
I should have taken my call uh I just
recently retired and my whole working
career I tagged on my gross and I'm
accessing my IRA I just curious any
thoughts about how to do that kind of
tithing oh that's a good question
there's 500 500 000 in there I'm drawing
1200 a month well good for you Jerry
how's that feel to retire and and doing
it so well
yeah no mortgage or no other debt either
good job well done Jerry well done
well you um yeah I mean when it comes to
the tithe you know from a Biblical
perspective we teach
um the 10 off your first fruits which
you did you know as you said through all
that so so where you're at now
um on us on a spiritual side I I'd never
like to be legalistic about tithing or
giving I want it to be you know I think
it's a great practice and one that we
teach here at Ramsey to be giving at
least 10 percent of your income but I
don't consider retirement savings income
uh but again not to be legalistic so if
you felt the spirit move that you you
want to to give more and you have the
ability to then I think you absolutely
can I wouldn't I don't think you have to
be obligated but with money yeah yeah I
asked because this yield is gross some
of it was gross that's right that's
right yes yes if you're getting
technical in that sense you're exactly
right
um but you know with all money we always
say you just can give it you can save it
you can spend it and we need to be doing
all three all the time so I would still
be giving and be generous uh even into
your retirement years because I think
that that's just part of our DNA and how
we're made up that we are created to be
givers and when we're giving and serving
it is part of of who we are and how we
were created so I don't want you to miss
out on that but I don't want you to feel
tied down
um or in a legalistic sense that it has
to be 10 of the tithe uh but that that
would be my opinion Christina what do
you think yeah I totally agree I think
that if you had tied like if you hadn't
tied it off gross we would be having a
different conversation
um but with you typing off growth
throughout building up your retirement
savings I'm right there with you and I
think if you do want to give just out of
generosity and out of your heart you
have a lot of freedom to do that right
now but really good job on reaching this
spot I think that's the dream for a lot
of people getting to retirement and just
feeling that Freedom no mortgage nothing
holding you back no debt yeah I saw a
stat Jerry recently I think it and I
think it said less than 20 percent of
Christians tithe in general so even
throwing in the words gross the net no
one's doing it anyway so the fact that
you're you're giving at any point I
think is a really great Habit to be in
so I don't want you to get tied down to
any of that okay well that's a great
good philosopher then that helps a lot
okay that's great Jerry thanks so much
for the call you know giving is uh
it's it is a part of the money message
that I don't hear a lot of people in the
financial space really harp on but this
is a big part of why you do the things
you do you guys with money this is why
you budget and you're intentional this
is why you work your way out of debt
this is why you have a savings
um an emergency fund so you can take
care of your own household and make sure
if anything happens that you have the
ability to pay for it this is why you
save for the future all of this uh
giving throughout it all but then the
end exclamation point of getting to baby
step seven which means you are investing
your everything is paid for including
your mortgage and you get to build
wealth and give generously so that
giving part is so huge you guys and to
start no matter where you are so those
of you on baby step one saving your
thousand dollars still be giving be
giving something give a little until you
can give a lot because if you're not
giving a little when you have little
it's actually harder to give when you
have more people think if I just had
more money I would give and that's not
always the case a lot of money habits
are created
um and then just magnified as you build
wealth so if giving is not a habit that
you have even starting out it's not like
it just magically appears one day you
really it's part of it's an exercise
right it's a strength a muscle that you
grow uh throughout your life and and the
benefit of it's wonderful right and I
think the thing is is I love that you
hit on the legalistic aspect of it this
is not something that you're doing to
check a box to just you know sleep
better at night because it's something
you felt obligated to do like this is
something to do out of an abundance of
the heart and you talk in your book
about having that abundance mindset and
how it can just help so much in so many
different areas of life and so it's just
important to you know sea giving as a
joy in the process we are all about
giving but like in giving you're making
a difference in people's lives you're
getting to sew forward you're making an
impact and that's all very exciting
stuff it's not something to feel heavy
and kind of like oh that's right well
and what's so I think interesting in
today's world we are such a
self-centered culture right like
everything is about me me me me me me my
happiness my job my what I look like
what I want if I'm happy I mean it's
just it's it's all about me and you live
your life like that for a long period of
time and and the truth is like you end
up being a very self-centered person
like yeah that's the product of when you
just look at yourself and that's it and
so when you give you move on that aspect
of being selfish to self-less and you
actually bring your eyes up and look at
other people and and see other people
hear their stories know what's going on
in the world being able to use money as
a tool to help with those things whether
it's a non-profit or a Ministry or or an
individual that you're helping
um well I think it's even going to make
you better in your own job because it's
like if you have your eyes up and you're
seeing people a lot of jobs like what
you're doing is serving other people so
it's like you already have that mindset
of like I'm looking around I'm not so
self-focused that I'm like wanting to
you know that I'm not just looking at
myself I'm looking at other people and
saying in my career in my job how can I
provide more value how can I serve
others how can I show up for other
people in a way that eventually
generates income for you but it's really
out of the abundance of the heart it's
out of wanting to do a good job for
other people yes and in the career and
then I'm like yeah and in your marriage
when you're selfless you're like you're
a much better spouse when you're like
hey how you know what do you need in
this what what can I when you serve when
there is a a servant's heart in that or
a parents right in your parenting or in
a friendship right you know like it's
it's unbelievable just that selflessness
and where it can start with the thing
that we grip type the most which is our
money right you could open your hands
and allow giving and again you guys I
know some of you starting out you're
like are you kidding me I'm living
paycheck to paycheck we can barely make
our bills I would even encourage you to
cut something just to be able to give
that's good just cut the Hulu
subscription and have to and buy two
coffees for someone this way like what
like even just small things but you
start that practice and I'm like it
changes your heart it changes your
outlook in life I really believe that
and and I think as a as a Christian you
know we were created in God's image and
he is a giver and so our DNA and who we
are we're created to be that when you
live that out it changes your life so
spiritually or not if you're someone
walking in faith or not I still
encourage you be giving something give a
little until you can give a lot so
thanks Jerry for that original call this
segment this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Ramsay personality Rachel Cruz hosting
with Christina Ellis this hour going to
the phones we have Kelsey in Cincinnati
hey Kelsey welcome to the show
hi Rachel hi Christina thank you so much
for this opportunity to talk to you yeah
absolutely how can we help
okay well let me sum it up really simply
here my mother is spending so much money
our business is in debt and I don't know
what to do about that okay also
we had sold a part of our business to a
gentleman who is a family friend
and now he's coming back to us saying
that he wants to walk away from the deal
and I don't know what to do
can you unpack that a little bit what
did this deal look like what does
walking away look like
sure so we were under a lease for five
years at a location and it was a retail
store offering product
the gentleman came to us for a year
wanting to buy the store he didn't have
the whole lump sum money that we were
asking for up front so what are
instead of beliefs with him was that we
would walk for a year with a certain
portion given each month and then at the
end of one year he gave us the rest and
like a balloon wrap
January would have been the time for him
to bring us back the rest of the money
now he's telling us his final month is
November and he has to walk away but he
would potentially like to come back in
maybe six months but he's not sure oh my
gosh Kelsey
were you guys looking to sell
yeah I mean we had two retail locations
and our manufacturing wholesale size
that's two different businesses and of
itself for one family yeah we can't
maintain all of this it's overwhelming
yeah it's a lot what does the contract
look like with this family friend
so it was a sublease
um through us for right now until he
paid
off the full portion and it was just
that he paid us a certain amount each
month and then at the end of one year to
give him time to get a loan to buy the
business entirely he would give us the
rest of the balloon lump what kind of
obligation do you have to him
to him we don't have anything with the
person that we're leasing the property
through it was a five-year lease we
could terminate the lease with a penalty
of six months worth of rent the only
problem is our company doesn't even have
that amount to give to walk away from
all of this yeah because there's no
money okay so how much did he have left
that he should have paid
uh it was approximately
sixty some thousand sixty thousand okay
and it was there a contract or was this
a handshake
it was a contract okay so you have legal
documentation that he owes you guys
sixteen thousand dollars
yes okay
I mean
I mean Kelsey at this point I mean he he
had he's in a contractual relationship
with you all that he owes you sixty
thousand dollars and now he's not giving
it to you he's and so with the terms of
of everything in the contract I mean
that's in my head I'm like that's where
a lawsuit comes into play and I know
he's a family friend but at this point
like he's not doing what he said he was
gonna do and almost thank God for a
contract that you have something legally
to back it up for you guys because for a
lot of people they do a handshake and
there is no paperwork there is no legal
documentation or evidence
um but in your case I mean like have you
guys thought about going the lawsuit
route and suing him for this money
I really don't want to do that because
for one by the time we get done paying
the fees and everything it's not going
to be worth very much also the reason
why he's backing away isn't because he
doesn't enjoy the business it's because
it was either that or his home
so that's why he wanted a six-month
break give us back everything and then
possibly come back to it when he's in a
more financially stable situation and he
probably won't so if we just pretended
for a second that you guys went though
just pretend y'all went to lawsuit he
doesn't have sixty thousand dollars to
give except for his for a house
mm-hmm that you'd force them in that
well man
tell us a little bit more about your mom
you said your mom's spending a lot of
money and that's not really sustainable
right so I just found out a situation
today that really I sent her a text
message that I'm very disappointed and
I'll I'll unpack it so my family was
raised on her side of borrow from Paul
to pay Peter mentality she didn't want
that for us kids I'm currently going
through Financial Peace University on
baby step 3A for my family
but for my mom and dad they're not they
did just recently pay off all their
personal credit cards but now because
the business doesn't have enough money
in its bank account all the business
credit cards are maxed out she has used
personal credit card
to buy business inventory
and today I saw an email thread with
another vendor of ours and she was
getting ready to make another purchase
with one of her personal cards
and I asked her does Dad know that
you're doing this you guys just paid off
your cards yeah so that's why we're
having a family emergency meeting
tonight because two days ago we just
discussed how everyone needs to know
what's going on with the financial
situation and what being
bought what does this business look like
so you're in business with your parents
and with your mom specifically
with my mom's
specifically and then all of my siblings
and we do have employees as well are you
guys all owners of the company and it's
split five ways or how does that work
every child gets a portion of the
business when they turn 21. as of right
now two siblings qualify the other two
will eventually okay
in this business you said it's got a lot
of debt is it profitable at this point
like what did the finances look like on
this business
as of right now it has the potential to
be very profitable I I'm more of a black
and white person I like numbers I enjoy
that side of it but it has the potential
but there's so much debt that's
outstanding it's there's no profit we
owe money to family members and Friends
and credit cards and loans and yeah it's
just overwhelming so I'm just gonna
talk to you directly not for the whole
family business and talk as if I were in
your shoes if I were in your shoes I'd
be trying to get out of this business
like your mom created this business she
said she's adding the kids in as like a
gift as some sort of thing that's
supposed to be a great thing but this
doesn't sound great this sounds like a
burden for you this is stressful it's
not structured well your mom is spending
like crazy and if I run your shoes I'd
be running for the hills just trying to
see what I could do to get my family out
of it and set us up for Success because
at this point like this is a sinking
ship well and what's hard Kelsey is the
person that is you know making these
these bad financial moves within the
business to your mom you can't control
her and so until you guys have a set of
whatever it is bylaws values that you
guys run the company by and say this is
what we're doing and if we don't do this
here are the here's the boundary here
are the consequences of what's going to
happen beyond that because like
Christina's right I'm not gonna sit in
this mess and just it here because I'm a
family member no I'm Kelsey you you know
you're an adult with a with your own
family that you're trying to take care
of and so
um this has not become a a um a gift
it's become a nightmare and so for your
mom's sake you know I mean I almost at
this family meeting tonight would say
Mom I can't control what you do with
money so on the personal side I applaud
that you and Dad got out of debt but
whatever you guys do on the personal
side of your life I have no I can
encourage you if you want my opinion I
can give it to you but I can't control
that now when it comes to the business
we now have our business hats on we're
no longer family members and that and
that's we are co-owners in a business
and it's someone who is a co-owner is
misrepresenting the business and is or
are doing things financially that we
don't agree if you guys if you guys all
agree that this is not okay and so
setting those and treating her even
though I know she ended up like if you
have me as part of the owner you're
going to hear my opinion and unless we
do this because we're drowning and it's
not working I'm gonna have to set that
back
I'm gonna have to set that boundary and
so if it's on that if it um that's on
the business side and then when it comes
to the family friends you know I mean
you either have to eat it or you gotta
you gotta sue them
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
s.com blinds.com 100 satisfaction
guarantee means even if you mismeasure
or pick the wrong color they will remake
your blinds for free so get free samples
at free shipping and with the new promo
codes they run every month you'll save
even more use promo code Ramsay to get
the best deal today's question comes
from Haley in Virginia my boyfriend has
talked about proposing sometime in the
coming months I know I want to marry him
but there is one thing holding me back
from committing completely he has a ton
of debt he's a full-time college student
at a private university and has around
thirty thousand dollars in debt already
he doesn't have a job so he is just
continuing to accrue the debt and not
pay on it I'm a full-time college
student but I also work a full-time job
I have no debt at all and it is very
concerning to me that I would be taking
in all of his debt if I marry him now
how do we navigate this wow well I think
very first thing is to have that
conversation because the fact that
you're thinking about marriage with this
guy and he's continuing to accrue debt
um that's an issue it'd be one thing if
he like had debt and you guys are on the
same page and you're going to tackle it
when you're married but the fact that he
has it and doesn't seem concerned about
it he doesn't really want to work to pay
it off and he's just kind of continuing
to take it on I think you guys have to
have a real level setting conversation
to go okay here's how I view money this
is my goal for the future I don't want
to have debt I'm working really hard now
while a full-time student so that I can
have you know freedom in the future and
won't be stressed by money if we're
going to enter into this agreement
together if we're going to be married
I don't want to live my life that way
yeah yeah the dollar amount honestly
Haley concerns me less because I
wouldn't say not to marry someone
because they have debt I mean yeah that
doesn't bother me but what value what
bothers me is the values conversation
where you're saying Christina like if he
says oh yeah I don't care
um about having debt and I'm gonna you
know have credit card debt I'll probably
take out car loans all that then your
values are off at that point and that's
the conversation you guys need to have
and get even deeper to the why you know
like why don't you want to have debt
what's your why is it because
um you know how you grew up and you're
fearful is it because you've experienced
not having margin before and it stresses
you out is it because you know you want
this feeling of security like what's
your why for living debt free and I want
to know his why if if he does I don't
want to put this on him but I'm assuming
you know he's somewhat okay with debt or
he's just as a he's a college or he's 20
years old and he's a normal college
student in the world and doesn't know
there's another way but if you you know
you guys talk about it and he still was
like no I don't care because I want to
enjoy my life and I want to whatever the
thing is that he's okay living in that
then again that's a values conversation
that you guys have to have and the truth
is is that money fights and money
problems is one of the leading causes of
divorce in America today
I had a friend in emmer he was like yeah
if like
the if like the number one reason people
died in your neighborhood was because of
bears people would be reading about
bears they'd be freaked out about bears
there'd be meetings about bears everyone
would be talking about bears and it's
like how do we avoid the Bears how do we
get them away how do the strategies I
mean right people can be freaked out and
so when you hear one of the leading
causes of divorce when you're entering a
marriage you should be like okay what do
we do about this like it should be and
on fire so I feel that urgency from you
Haley which I'm so thankful to hear that
because it is a big deal but also it's
less about the dollar amounts of I mean
if I if if Winston Cruz back in the day
had two hundred thousand dollars in debt
but he said never again we're not doing
it I would still marry him and we would
have a we'd have a road to climb to get
out together as a married couple because
I'd still marry him I love him you know
uh but I think it's important like if he
says so you have this values
conversation and he says okay I'm
willing to change I I wanted I didn't
realize that taking out student loans
wasn't something I should do I want to
get on board have a great financial
future like I think after that before
you get married it's good to see
evidence of change like that it's not
just a conversation where he's like yeah
and then the next semester he takes out
another you know fifteen thousand
dollars in debt like especially at this
phase you're in where there's like a
very obvious outcome
um in terms of is he going to take on
more debt or not pay attention to that
because I mean if he really wants to
marry you and he's excited to marry you
um we don't want him to just say he's
compromising or you know say something
so that you know you get across you know
the the marriage line and then he
doesn't actually change so I think you
have an opportunity to also see you know
once you have that conversation how he
perceives yep some evidence in it yeah
but great question Haley all right up
next we have Julia in Raleigh North
Carolina welcome to the show
hi good afternoon thank you so much for
taking my call can you hear me okay yes
we can yeah how can we help
all right
um so actually so I just came across you
Rachel and the way I came across is I um
I was looking for ways of getting or to
pay for my co the college
um tuition for my last born and then
shortly after I think it was O'Neill and
Dave Ramsey then you've popped on and
then you started talking about the seven
baby steps so I wanted to know how that
works and if my husband is like
absolutely not on board at all what can
I do about that and basically to give
you a little bit of background is
um we're both truck drivers and
um during this last two weeks that I've
been listening every night because I
have all the time in the world yeah but
I'm driving I get to listen to you guys
and get a lot of
um positive resources out of your show I
actually happened to pass by Tennessee
and I was like oh my gosh this was fine
because all this time we've been driving
I never knew where you are yeah that's
great I heard about you but Juliet we
have a heart there we are okay we have a
heart out here in about two minutes so
so uh let me get to your question so
your question mostly is about the baby
steps
um and how to get your spouse on board
okay so where are you financially Julia
how much debt do you guys have
so we have a business a trucking
business is a small company so it's
between the house and the uh the
business it's had a million a little bit
over a million okay let's separate those
numbers so just give me your just your
house how much do you owe in your house
500 500 okay 500. do you guys have any
credit card debt
yes okay how much is that so the crazy
thing is we had just paid half a year
ago oh yeah and then we got it all back
okay because of the business so we have
I don't have the numbers but last year
we paid off the credit cards and it was
about a hundred and Seventeen uh between
the both of us
is that for the business Juliet
no that's for the credit cards for the
credit cards personal okay and and you
don't know how much current credit card
debt you have though not how much you
paid off but currently
um currently I would say
let me see me alone I have like about a
hundred because I have a like about 15
credit cards so me alone about a hundred
and thirty thousand dollars in credit
card debt and that's just Consumer Debt
yes okay uh car loans
uh we paid off the cars okay and I have
a student loan of 75
000. 75 okay how much you guys make a
year yeah
um
let me see each truck so we had three
trucks but we sold we're selling it slow
how much do you guys yeah how much do
you and your husband bring in every
month for your own income
um between 30
240
000 a month before
um yes before everything is taken wow
okay you guys are doing great
also I don't see the money no you don't
because you have you have a crap ton of
debt Juliet so here's the deal okay so
what you're going to do is you're going
to list out all of your debts some of
it's a little foggy so you're gonna
you're gonna find hard evidence and even
if it's multiple credit cards list them
all out separately okay Juliet
everything is separate list out all of
your debts not including your mortgage
smallest to largest you're gonna pay
minimum payments on everything and
you're gonna start attacking the
smallest debt first and hold on the line
Austin's gonna pick up we're going to
give you and your husband Financial
Peace University for a year it's going
to come with every dollar which is our
budgeting app and I want you and your
husband to sit down and if you can if
you can force them you just tell them
you've got to sit down here with me and
watch that first video okay that's gonna
explain the nuts and bolts of exactly
what you're about to walk through and
you guys can clean this up you have an
incredible income Juliet your life could
look drastically different in six months
and if you guys put the hard work in and
you sacrifice you can get this cleaned
up thanks for calling
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
our scripture of the day comes from
Jeremiah 17 7 but blessed is the one who
trusts in the Lord whose confidence is
in him
success is most often achieved by those
who don't know that failure is
inevitable
Coco Chanel thank you gentlemen in the
booth did y'all pull a quote
for me not that I have Chanel but
fashion I appreciate that thanks Austin
uh all right you guys if you love this
show if it's something you listen to on
a regular basis Please Please Subscribe
uh to our YouTube channel to podcast uh
hit the follow button there leave a
review share it with your friends with
your family
honestly word of mouth is one of the
best ways for this show to grow and for
us to really hit the toxic money culture
heart the more people we can get on
board that are free from debt that are
in control of their money that is that's
when the world starts to change we're
not dependent on all these toxic
Financial Industries and and it's fun to
do this in community like it's fun to do
this with other people like if your
dinner table conversations with your
friends can be about you know how you
all are paying off debt and Building
Wealth like those are just such
wonderful stimulating conversations yes
which most people don't have because
people don't talk about money but you
know what money is not a shameful topic
you could talk about it and and
encourage people because it can be a
very stressful uh guilt-ridden subject
in life and when you even can give
encouragement to people on what you're
doing and your story and your journey uh
it's just helpful it really is all right
so yesterday Christina
uh we launched which I'm so excited
about a brand new Rachel Cruz slim
wallet so we have the ritual Cruise
wallet that has all the envelopes and so
this is a smaller version of that it has
one envelope but multiple card slots
that can hold your cards from your
license and Costco and debit card all
those things and it is genuine leather
it comes in three colors black camel and
champagne and we um
produced it with our friends at join
their incredible organization out of
India where they provide fair trade jobs
to really vulnerable communities and to
help them be employed so they're an
amazing organization so we're so
thankful to partner with them uh so yeah
if you guys uh or if you've been doing a
budget for a while and the cash envelope
systems if you're kind of graduating out
of it because eventually you kind of get
to the point that you're like I don't
need that hard accountability of actual
cash
this is another great option to still
have one envelope that you can always
have cash with but also just the
convenience of just carrying your cards
so and it's so pretty I just saw
yesterday oh it's lovely thank you thank
you thank you yeah so check out the
Rachel Cruz slim wallet available now
for 39 but if you go to
ramseysolutions.com you can check out
all the colors everything we have going
on there so make sure to check it out
all right up next we have Jordan in
California hey Jordan welcome to the
show
hey Rachel thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can we help
um so I'm trying to get a mortgage
um I'm 100 debt free and I haven't had a
credit history
um and uh
uh personal mortgage is not able to do
the underwriting
because I don't have a rental history or
any housing history
because I've been living with my parents
okay so I'm wondering where to go next
and what to do there
um do you guys have a good down payment
saved up
yeah we have 400 000. oh wow that's
amazing
yeah so um a couple of options Jordan
you can either go try other other
um mortgage brokers other lenders you
can even talk to like a local credit
union
um some other people that do still
manual underwriting uh but I'm gonna say
that the rental history is a big one to
have and so that's why we do recommend
people renting
um for a short period of time just to
have that did they say a specific
timeline of how much they would need to
see
12 months 12 a full year
Yeah because sometimes they'll do even
just six months and you rent just to get
that fact on paper so you don't have to
go you know
build up a credit score which I would
never encourage you to do so um so yeah
so that that would be an option that you
could look at other look at other
lenders ask around have get different
options
um but again I think that that rental
history is an important factor yeah
underwriting process do you have like an
urgency right now are you trying to move
out in a certain timeline or kind of
what's your what's your forecast for
when you want to do this
uh no we're just now that my wife's done
with school we're we're now ready to buy
now that she's working full-time
um we're just in a position that you
know we want to buy so I'm just trying
to get all my ducks in a row and y'all
have done a great job that's a great job
amazing is that just from working
uh yeah so we had a house like three
years ago okay okay
um so that's what half of that is gotcha
gotcha and have you been living with
your parents the rest of the three years
yeah okay and how long have you guys
been married
uh 11 years okay congratulations
and are you pretty settled in the city
you're in you're in you said your wife
just graduated
um are you all going to stay there for
her job
uh yeah we're gonna stay so uh
I'm all my clients are around here and
we're not moving anywhere soon so
okay yeah I mean Jordan I mean for me
I'm not going into debt for any reason
I'm not going to go play the credit card
game to get the credit score and all
that so either it's going to be getting
a mortgage from a different uh broker
broker and so shop around ask around I
would talk to three four different
people and see if there were other
um other means that you can show maybe
even when you guys had your first house
if you can pull the mortgage you know
the payments from from that uh to have
proof for that but again I mean you guys
have an incredible Nest Egg to buy an
incredible house again there's not a
there's not a rush I know you want to
um but if the only thing it came down to
was like I need 12 months of rental then
I'm like okay well we're gonna go rent
somewhere for a little bit get the get
the history we need and then save up
keep saving I mean you're it's just
giving you more time to save even more
and then and then go in and and buy the
home so I'm not I'm not playing that
game personally so
I'm not going to advise you to do that
yeah I'm with you and I mean you guys
are doing so well with that down payment
at the extra year of savings is great I
mean I don't know what kind of price
range you're looking at but you're
pretty close to being able to buy some
level of house debt free which that
would be outstanding incredible okay
we're gonna go to this last call we have
about two minutes but is it raw and
Savannah
hey yes how are you good how are you how
can we help
good thank you um all right so my mom
recently came into some money
and I'm wanting to um
kind of help her manage it so and see
what devices move for her would be okay
how much money
um she came 77 000 77 000.
yes okay and how old is your mom yeah 63
years old okay she's wanting to retire
next year how much does she have in
retirement
this is it
oh she just has the 77 000 okay yeah
um so she wants to is she gonna be able
has she run the numbers out has she
talked to a financial advisor to say
okay you know if I put this in I'm gonna
I mean she's not gonna have enough to
retire off of just that right
right I mean she's right yeah I mean um
she's she or she's going to get a
thousand dollar check per month uh
through social social security
okay um she pays 500 in rent right now
okay and she's uh she's a hair stylist
on the side okay she has her cosmetology
how much does she make now
uh right now she's I would say with her
job in cosmetology she's making like
2500 a month a month okay
does she have a mortgage now
no she rents I'm sorry you said that I
apologize yeah you did say that
um okay well I mean I had to say with
these numbers though she's not going to
be in a position probably to to retire
at this point
um she's gonna either have to get her an
income up
um and keep and keep putting money away
but I would uh recommend you guys go
look at a smartvester pro on Dave Ramsey
or ramseysolutions.com and sit down and
run the numbers and just look to see
okay how much does she need to have in
her nest egg in order because she may
not need a lot to live off of but she
needs some and it's probably getting and
she's 62 so she still could have 20 30
years you know still here so you want to
make sure that there's enough and
doesn't seem like there's enough right
this moment thanks for the call thanks
to everyone in the booth thank you
Christina for co-hosting today so fun
this has been the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramseysolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]